[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie grazie grazie grazie grazie
voici dal futuro voci per il futuro hai
Peccato che il mio atteggiamento verso
la musica verso la voce si è sempre
stato di tipo retro futuristico perché
sono nato col vinile sono nato con un
riproduttore audio vecchio anni 70 e
questo mi ha consentito già da allora
di intraprendere questo viaggio in tre
dimensioni dove l'ascolto del corpo e
della mente erano un tutt'uno molto
prima che le smartphone Prima ancora
prima il walkman rovinassero tutta
questa cosa e nei miei studi Sono
arrivato a concludere che ci sono
quattro elementi fondamentali del suono
che vanno presi in considerazione quando
sia nell'ascolto attivo ovvero quando
suono quando canto nell'ascolto passivo
Quando ascolto semplicemente uno parlare
o un disco questi quattro elementi sono
il suono inteso come timbro come
armoniche
la dinamica come il suono varia nel
tempo sia in un tempo limitato
microdinamica che in un tempo più esteso
macro dinamica il tempo musicale cioè
come noi suonasse ideale del tempo
definito in BPM o definito da un
direttore d'orchestra mettiamo note e
pause e l'intonazione che viene
denominata altezza che può essere
settata 4-32 con la 432 440 quindi ci
sono tanti variabili in un sistema di
decafonico di 12 suoni identici che però
perfetti non lo sono mai
e quindi
mi sono ritrovato a dover risolvere un
sacco di sfighe perché da quando ho
preso intrapreso questo questo viaggio
mi sono ritrovato a
far fatica
a far fatica a sentire le cose come
secondo me nell'ascolto passivo erano
e poi come facciamo a definire un suono
in quattro modi mentre lo ascoltiamo
Come si fa deve già essere messo il
suono giusto poi come facciamo
correggere errori se non ci sono quindi
la nostra mente Anziché cercare di fare
una cosa giusta Ne fa quattro
leggermente sbagliate e cavolins che è
una giusta farne quattro sbagliate non è
una bella media giusto e quindi
Come si fa per arrivare da dove si sente
occorre pensare al suono sia che con
l'ausilio di uno strumento o con la voce
prima che questo venga messo e pensarlo
già finito attraverso l'ausilio il
filtraggio dell'istinto quello che mia
madre e mia nonna mi hanno insegnato
a riconoscere per riconoscerla la mia
verità per riconoscere tutto quello che
è vero Per me non con delle dottrine ma
bensì con un facendo leva su un senso di
responsabilità nei confronti di me
stesso cioè riuscire a cantare suonare
bene e suonare bene una parte musicale
in modo naturale che rispetti canoni
musicali Ok ma che rispetti anche il mio
corpo la mia mente non è una cosa facile
richiede tanti tante ore di studio ma
soprattutto consapevolezza ed è normale
che un musicista a un certo punto faccia
i conti con la propriocezione
e anch'io ho fatto quella fine lì ora
voglio farvi un quesito se avete un
figlio di 8 anni che vuole suonare il
pianoforte foste ricchi sfondati e vi
chiede papà voglio tua mamma Voglio un
pianoforte e compreresti un piano da 2k
o da 200k Provate a pensarci alzate la
mano 2k
nessuno Questo tutti bene al mondo 200k
gli altri non si suona chi se ne frega
Ok benissimo Ok
benissimo questo non funziona molto bene
Ok
arrivo eh quindi questo interrogativo lo
pongo perché alla fine nessuno chiede al
bambino cosa vuole ed è lì è nata la mia
esigenza di scoprire che cos'è la
maieutica durante un mio workshop una
dottoressa mi chiese molto bravo con la
maieutica Complimenti Non sempre neanche
cosa fosse E allora sono andato un po'
documentare e ho capito che era una cosa
naturale per me cercare di estrapolare
sensazioni o pensieri da chi avevo
vicino che fosse un allievo che fosse un
collega questo per arrivare un risultato
che io avevo già in mente
la premessa è che io non sono qui per
intrattenervi perché altrimenti vi avrei
meritato un mio concerto giusto Non sono
qua neanche per stupirvi ma sono qua per
condividere un'esperienza che mi ha
permesso di conoscere molto me stesso
Infatti il dovere di qualsiasi artista o
musicista che sia e di mettere al centro
la performance al netto D me stesso le
paure al netto di tutti quelli che
possono essere gli interessi coinvolti
ma soprattutto al netto dei limiti che
spesso sono imposti da chi vuole che
l'asticella sia sempre tenuta più basso
perché la gente non capisce allora la
gente capisce e la gente soprattutto
sente
E sebbene fossi il peggior studente
della storia probabilmente ho sempre
pensato che comunque le cose potessero
essere fatte meglio e questo mantra me
lo sono portato avanti anche perché per
trovare pace tra cuore e testa
e dopo tanti sensi di colpa e né da
sensi di energia di accuratezza sensi di
anche di buttarsi un po' via sono
arrivato alla conclusione che se volevo
concludere qualcosa nella vita dovevo
dedicarmi a qualcosa che mi avrebbe
permesso di accrescere il mio interesse
giorno dopo giorno e soprattutto la
nonna leoni armi e quindi tornando
l'approccio retro futuristico come io
forse avrei voluto fare le cose e ho
notato che
la praticità e la convenienza sono i
nemici nello studio delle cose e
hanno comprato il mio primo
sintetizzatore a 13 anni mi regalarono
uno strumento vero quello che avevano
quelli veri e io ho 13 anni Insomma io
me lo merito questo strumento Sì e mi
sentivo come un astronauta nello Space
Shuttle dove l'unico limite ero io
Quelli erano dei tempi li potevo solo
migliorare Ora voglio condividere al
volo un po' delle mie ricerche nate
appunto Da queste sfighe
La prima è quella della latenza scoprire
che oggi quando registri la tua voce C'è
un ritardo che se anche di un
millisecondo comunque crea una sorta di
blocco tra te la tua gola la tua testa e
la tua gabbia toracica e questo blocco
può essere risolto soltanto se volete ve
lo dico dopo Se vi interessa comunque
è un blocco che comunque compromette
molto eh la sensazione che tu provi
mentre canti è un po' come Quando
scrivete il cellulare Le lettere non
escono vi incavolate giusto è la stessa
cosa e quindi la fluidità la libertà e
la reattività che il suono ha e sono gli
elementi che contraddistinguono un suono
libero e spontaneo da un suono pensato e
noioso una volta che ho fatto un test su
300 persone E tutte hanno preferito il
monitoraggio diretto vuol dire che se
anche non sei un esperto in audio se
anche Non riconosci gli elementi ma se
gli elementi ci sono li senti se li
senti la scelta è sempre quella che ti
porta verso l'effetto libero quindi
verso la libertà poi un'altra cosa che è
stata parte dei miei studi è stata la
compensazione Siccome il cervello
Insomma compensa anche quando non glielo
chiedi a un certo punto ho deciso visto
che il risultato che ottenevo era sempre
un po' scarno di prendermi in giro Cioè
ho cominciato a enfatizzare nel mio
Ascolto le frequenze alte
perché le avevo in eccesso e toglievo le
frequenze basse perché ne avevo un
difetto mi ritrovavo che quello che
trovavo alla fine era esattamente quello
che avevo in testa nel senso che non
riuscivo a realizzare il suono che
volevo perché ero compromesso dal mio
ascolto estemporaneo ho fatto questa
prova con
2.500 Allievi in 25 anni ovviamente E
questa cosa funziona sempre questo
questa sorta di compensazione
estemporanea questo mi è permesso di
fermamente di ricavare il mio suono
quello che veramente vogliono quello che
penso di avere perché le condizioni non
mi permettono di tirarlo fuori uno degli
ultimi studi che ho fatto è quello della
destra a sinistra un giorno mi cade una
birra mentre ascolto una roba e sento
che a destra e sinistra sento due robe
diverso allora ho detto che cosa succede
poi mi sono messo a far mastering che è
l'ultima operazione che si fa nelle
produzioni audio e quella che diciamo è
il tocco finale e ed è partito il mio
agio in 3D ho capito che l'orecchio
sinistro percepisce tutto quello che è
all'esterno di me
l'orecchio destro invece riceve il suono
dice Io direi che che funziona
esattamente uguale Assolutamente no E
questa cosa l'ho provata con tante
persone perché dopo vi spiego perché ho
le bacchette non sono un batterista
però Se provate a fare questa cosa
chiudete l'orecchio destro
è gratis Eh non costa niente vi mettete
così e Parlate con la mano sinistra
davanti alla bocca sentirete che il
suono lo percepite all'esterno Se fate
il contrario Il suono lo percepite
all'interno
ora quindi siccome il suono
il 70% del suono è costituito
dall'ambiente quindi l'ambiente Insomma
è un azionario che che ne ha a questo
punto nazionista scusate
Qual è l'orecchio del musicista quindi
il sinistro il destro e come avere un
navigatore il destro mi dice dove sono
il sinistro mi dice dove devo andare
quindi quando mi hanno operato di
cervicale e dovevo decidere dove farmi
tagliare Ovviamente mi sono fatto
tagliare qui perché se non avessero
tagliato qui avrei perso 30 anni di
sensibilità di studi e di propriocezione
Ok quindi è molto importante anche
capire che quando ascoltiamo qualcosa
questo qualcosa è messo così
e quindi se metto un suono crescente a
sinistra Anche se lo metto calante di
qua e sensazione è negativa perché ho le
bacchette perché per provare questa cosa
mi sono messo a tenere il tempo agli
allievi lì dicevo Chiudi l'orecchio
destro poi mi allontanavo Adesso non
posso perché c'è il bollino rosso ma e
vorrei allontanarmi ma non posso
comunque 15 metri fanno 90 millisecondi
90 millisecondi musica sono un'infinità
però gli allievi con l'orecchio sinistro
libero continuo andare a tempo
col destro no Quindi vuol dire che la
funzione destra e sinistra è una cosa
completamente diversa ora perché
dobbiamo semplificare l'ascolto se è una
cosa complessa se vogliamo veramente
arrivare a percepire quel corpo
dobbiamo fare questo tipo di trip e
questo triplo devo al batterista che mi
ha donato queste bacchette ovvero il mio
batterista sette anni che sono con
questo personaggio che è una leggenda
del rock si chiama Tommy aldridge e
suonando con lui mi ha chiamato la vita
io ho sentito dei recettori come cavolo
suona questo e la prima cosa che ho
pensato questo suona male perché il mio
cervello non andava d'accordo con quello
che faceva lì ma il mio corpo sentiva
tutto che movimento molto bello molto
buono Ok allora a quel punto lì ho detto
forse C'ha ragione lui ho ascoltato le
prove e ho capito a 40 anni che non
avevo capito niente grazie a lui Poi
sono andato a tavola con lui Grazie
Tommy mi hai fatto capire la differenza
tra le basse e le altre le basse le cui
percepisco Qui le altre lì e lui
continuava a mangiare Boom cosa stai
dicendo non aveva la minima idea di cosa
gli ho detto però me l'ha insegnata lui
e quindi devo lui è molto Cioè li devo
veramente tanto perché finalmente mi ha
fatto capire come veramente si ascolta
la musica Anche perché i toni
fondamentali della vostra voce e di
tutte le note che sentite sono tutti
medio bassi quindi che si percepiscono
attraverso il corpo ora diamo la
risposta al quesito di prima Potete
alzare la mano quelli dei due cappa
quelli poveri Ecco ok
quelli ricchi
chi non comprerebbe il pianoforte perché
non ha posto in casa niente nessuno
comunque
una volta vado a Boston giorno off vado
a Boston ho avuto la brutta idea di
provare il piano da 200k
e dopo il mio piano non l'ho suonato per
meno un anno perché era talmente
ricco di armoniche ricco di dinamiche
Insomma suonava lui a un certo punto ho
detto forse il mio piano non è un
granché ma però io Lo suonavo io sentivo
cosa faceva questo pianoforte Quindi la
risposta è che bisogna comprarli tutti e
due
perché uno
ti sviluppa la sensibilità e sensibilità
ti dà la possibilità di sentire un
milione di colori l'altro ne ha 16
Poveretto però devi fare il meglio che
puoi con questi 16 e capire qual è il
limite di uno strumento per capire qual
è il tuo limite per cui arrivare alla
fine e tirare le somme perché alla fine
comunque Bisogna sempre fare quello che
devi fare in quel momento lì ora Io non
ho bisogno di sentire che c'è un
elemento di disturbo quando mangio
qualcosa quando ascolto qualcosa non
devo per forza riconoscerlo non sono
Sherlock Holmes ok Però se sento che
qualcosa non va
probabilmente c'è qualcosa che non va
quello il compito del cervello con lo
studio e con con la passione eccetera di
andare a risolvere tutto quello che si
interpone tra me e un suono libero
quindi adesso io vi saluto Aspetta non
ho finito la cosa bella che però questo
tipo di ascolto e al quale io tengo
anche perché sto investendo molto nel
mio album ho bisogno che questo venga
ascoltato come si faceva una volta
perché se oggi ti metti ascoltare un
giradischi ti metti così dopo arriva
veramente la neuro e non va mica bene io
spendevo i miei pomeriggi così e questi
in questa esperienza mi manca molto ed è
quella cosa che vorrei tramandare Anche
perché uno fa star bene e soprattutto
porta veramente a benessere porta
d'equilibrio
la musica non è solo musica e io non sto
bene se la musica non suona bene alle
mie orecchie Grazie
[Applauso]